this movie is the culmination of wishes
from every boy and man from the 80s on
let's take every action star of
yesteryear and put them in a movie
together what would that be like well a
lot like The Expendables that's right
with stubble cuz this is a man's movie
for men don't laugh it took me a week to
grow this out
so the Expendables as you know is
machine guns mayhem and muscle that is
pretty much the gist of it like I said
every guy out there has wanted to see
all these actors in a movie together for
20 years and after 20 years of prayers
the Lord hath delivered now if you're
unaware the Expendables features
Stallone Jason Statham Jet Li 12 London
who's just an enormous blond human being
he looks like the Lich King at this
point Stone Cold Steve Austin the other
Old Spice guy you know the one who
wasn't trying to bang Alyssa Milano on
Twitter although I'm sure he wishes he
had Mickey Rourke Randy Couture ER and
angel Batista from Dexter I mean I like
him and all he just wasn't part of the
whole you know to put these guys in a
movie together prayers but he was good
now you really got to see The
Expendables for what it is it's just an
action-packed bloodbath of awesome and
for the people who about that I
mean what kind of movie do you think all
these actors were gonna be in together
you think they'd be in some sort of
Oscar contender or something you think
they were gonna be in a remake of Hamlet
together get real The Expendables is
directed by Sylvester Stallone the
director of Rambo for it's not gonna hit
you deep down where you live but dudes
in this movie are going to get blown in
half and that's awesome The Expendables
is for anyone who found any enjoyment in
the last Rambo movie if you hated Rambo
for don't even bother with the
Expendables you're not gonna like it and
I will say there was no single moment in
the Expendables 2 just blew my mind like
the 50 Cal scene at the end of Rambo for
that was bananas but there is a lot
of good action in this movie in the
climax of the Expendables as all sorts
of just dream come true for us guys not
gonna lie
we like this kind of I mean there's
good action in the beginning and there's
good action after the halfway point in
the movie but there's this section in
between which nothing really happens and
you're like come on Duke get to the guns
again if you paid to see this movie for
any other reason I just gotta ask why
but like I said the end of this movie
makes up for that hold dry spell in the
end you realize that this is the poster
child for 80s action movies and there
are a couple of surprise cameos in this
movie that would have been more
surprising if they didn't show it in the
trailer I'll profess til the day I die
they should not have shown
Kamio in the trailer I'm not even going
to say who it is on the off chance that
there is a human being out there that's
going to see The Expendables that hasn't
seen the trailer yet and they happen to
be watching this video right now so if
you're an 80s action junkie who just
wants some bloody mindless fun don't
watch the trailer just go watch the
movie you'll have a good time and if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more oh
yeah
tastes like ass
[Music]